welcome to this video one pawn one porn
that could be the one pawn the porn that
you have one vo wo n poem okay anyway
let's see we got a ques Indian or green
felt coming what is some his choice the
Kings Indian yeah I'm playing the h3
Bishop g5 line that was recently um
featured in a video series for the SSC
by grandmaster Alexia Malinsky I watched
a bit of it last night and then I fell
asleep not because it was a bad series
is just that I often watch chest videos
when I'm sitting in my bed and sometimes
when it's a bit too late i just felt
just fall asleep pretty much regardless
of who's doing the video um or what the
Condor does so is c5 is a bit a bit but
uncommon
okay i'm not quite sure sometimes you
can do a five on things like that enum
this position top but let's just play d5
isn't bad so um I guess I will take that
pawn yeah probably i could have played
t5 quick em but d take c5 is sometimes
interesting here queen air five though i
think was pretty much okay for black
yeah i know that looks a bit like a loss
of temper but what usually has to play
that move to be ready in form then pin
break that pin and solidify the center
thoes bishop moves to g5 and so on
that's a bit a bit slow but you really
have if you really have to do it
I think Bishop d3 is also was a
possibility had something very similar
in a league game only a couple of months
ago c4 it's an interesting move okay
let's let's develop not not losing on
time I need to get cancelled the move c4
is always a very a double-edged one
because black gets possibilities on the
d3 and CM @ b 3 square with the night
possibly coming on the other hand he's
also a weakening d for substantially so
that Knight to c6 becomes an option and
I think I'm doing this it's a very slow
way to play but the knight on c6 is
rather tempting to have so let's do it
yeah and his son spending ages Knight
takes d5 thus night xt5 attacking the
Queen night you for Queenie frost so he
has no discoveries with the night to g4
but i have from 96 then just winning
okay so knight c6 or capturing with one
of the one of the nights i take with the
sea knight is to go to be fire to see 5
and the should be three that looks a
very awkward let's do that threatening
knight c6 I'm not quite sure way is
going with the Queen I can check me huh
ok it was that was stupid knight c6 is
indeed strong but that check is as
possible anyway so then then probably
nights is 67 you see no Jen cannot take
on e4 or somewhere else here I just want
to I just don't want to fall into a
stupid some stupid tactic that I'm
overlooking like on f2 or so because my
development is not great but I'm
threatening Bishop e3 winning the Queen
and there's also c7 hanging and yeah all
kinds of things are wrong here for black
including the time Wow
we're down to one minute after 18 move
something really has gone wrong
okay 25 that's 97 so okay push rip III
2597 that's probably a relatively easy
way to do it then take on CA so just be
should be two and then cancelled on say
something something better you should be
two looks very sensible to be three
probably look a three yeah okay so
deform yeah that's still something to
take into account that deform
rookie one is sticking uniformity to
bishop is not it's not protected
hmm it's not entirely easy actually
don't have any great squares there okay
let's play move would've liked to not
not allow this activity but I didn't see
a way to avoid it fortunately it's got
sold a lot time the team that year
allowed 96 checks it drugs you one time
mornings enemies cannot use that really
Bishop f4 maybe looks you for something
okay yeah the bishop air is cool as you
know from our videos I like it
especially if I've got to two of them
and he doesn't have any peace for it
that makes the bishop a even stronger
check black resigns okay so let's let's
recap about that yeah I have my doubts
about those be five lines some in them
in lines like that they don't have a
greater reticle reputation anyway okay I
went here and here i am i'm not sure if
that is a really great idea i had the
computer is already giving this as a
very strong reply quite interesting
where is he going there and some 20
points this is the straps the queen
we go here then that seems to be strong
Wow okay thats its also just good right
yeah it's also one point something I
think c4 is probably just premature and
now 94 is strong I'm losing lots of time
but it's really it doesn't matter I a 96
plane was also very good because this is
also Queen trap okay but it's also when
I don't believe check it's not plus 3s
certain the end of yeah I don't think I
allowed anything anything special right
here rook see form I have ever had a
three I saw that but then he played
played something different yeah it's
just a win I simply believe that those
be five porn sacrifices against them
types like or on lines like same like
the arbor back home or h three castles
Bishop g5 I don't think that those lines
are correct also there's some there's
also this line which i believe is also
incorrect at is simply not enough
compensation for the pawns it's not a
banker where some it's really important
to to them to recognize okay well thanks
for watching